hey leute und verkommt zu einer neuen
map vorstellung heute stelle ich euch
die pforte in minecraft map von spring
vor viel spaß so und nun befinden wir
uns hier im inneren dieses redstone
kolosseums kann man schon sagen weil wir
hier draußen seht ist wirklich alles
eingezäunt von redstone mechanismen was
ich euch hier zeigen könnte wäre zum
beispiel dass wir hier auch diese
comment blogs dokument blog blogs finden
wo man dann die tp daten eingeben kann
wo man hingeht wird wenn man irgendwo
was gegen schießt ihr fragt euch jetzt
hin was sondern wogegen schießen
ganz einfach das ist halo minecraft es
hat gerade irgendwie gehabt ich weiß
nicht woran das lag
das ist einfach ihr habt hier überall
mein katzen wenn man gegen die gegen
schießt kommen da weil wenn man weiß am
roten teppich hat gegen schließt kommt
der lava raus und wenn man bei dem
lapislazuli gegen schluss kommt das
wasser raus das soll quasi diese portale
darstellen aber was ich euch davor noch
zeigen möchte ist dass ich heute den
skin von david 3790 an habe so sieht da
von hinten aus so sieht der von vorne
aus also von hinten traurig von vorne
lustig also ich fand den irgendwie ganz
witzig will mal wenn ihr skins wisst die
ich irgendwie anziehen soll dann
schreibt mir euren skin namen in die
kommentare
vielleicht wird er beim nächsten mal
dann gezeigt er ich zeige euch das mal
ganz kurz und zwar holte ich mir mal
ganz eben schnell die pfeile schießen
wir hier in mainz ab das fällt dann
dahin dann aktiviert sich das und hier
kommt lava aus und dann wollen wir zum
beispiel hierhin teleportieren dann
schießen wir da das mein card ab dann
kommt da fast heraus das heißt bestellt
jetzt hier vor die lava ihr denkt euch
jetzt bestimmt
man muss sich in die lava stellenportal
muss man auch da reingehen dann stirbt
er ja bestimmt nie es geht auch wenn ihr
euch einfach davor stellt dann werdet
ihr hier hin teleportiert jetzt steht
ihr hier und wir können das auch genau
so machen dass wir uns hier vor das
blaue stellen oder auch eingehen und
dann stehen wir hier nach also werden
halt genau zu dieser koordinate hin
teleportiert wir können auch einfach
hier wieder ein blaues mainka tab
schießen dann geht das da nämlich weg
und kommt dann dahin
dann werden wir auch wieder dahin
teleportiert so da sind wir wieder
und genau das gleiche funktion
auch mit dem roten also dass die lage
verändert sich dann auch die geht links
und rechts kommt zu dahin also ein ganz
einfaches spiel diese grafik hat
festlegen wir auch eingefügt dass canon
ein paar portal fans mit sicherheit dass
es eine der haupt grafiken die in dem
spiel irgendwo immer gezeigt wird und
ich finde allgemein diese idee all das
können ja noch ganz gut zeigen dass sie
wird nicht zu obsidian sondern das
fließt erst ab moment ach so das jetzt
blöd wenn ich da hinten noch des
anlegers das kann doch gar nicht sein
eigentlich und zwar wird wir könnten
noch mal probieren weil es gleichzeitig
abzuschießen
ich glaube das ist auch nicht möglich
nee also das ist eigentlich alles schon
perfekt durchdacht vor allem auch die
diese comment box ich zeige euch das
noch mal weil das einfach so hammermäßig
ist was er hier draußen wirklich alles
aufgebaut hat wenn man sich diese
comment box ihr ansieht wird man sieht
man wirklich das hier dieser redstone
schaltung hier ist zum beispiel mit
diesem portal da verbunden was da steht
und das heißt wenn man sich das
vorstellt die wird sich dieser kommentar
wird zu der anderen zahl halte noah in
teleportiert wir können nun die zahlen
verändern dann wird man woanders hin
teleportiert aber ich finde das so
eigentlich schon mal genial gemacht also
ein großes lob von mir ans netz bringen
finde ich genial findet den downloadlink
in der beschreibung findet facebook und
twitter in der beschreibung dort kriegt
immer informationen waren eventuell
neues video kommt oder allgemein
irgendwie sowas
ich würde mich über einen daumen hoch
freuen ich kann also fragen vielleicht
schaffen wir ja irgendwie zu 500 daumen
hoch das zeigt mir einfach dass ich
etwas richtig machen und dass euch das
auch gefällt und dann würde ich sagen
ich bin für dieses video raus schreibt
mir euren scannen die kommentare und ich
wünsche euch noch ein wundervollen tag
jetzt sagt sie gerade mit minecraft
minecraft alter habe ich behindert ist
das denn
meine fresse alter